Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show. My name is Jesse Dollar Moore. I'm subbing
for David this week. I'm kind of like UCAN
Kornelius, a cartoon from your your favorite
childhood Christmas special, animated by some
witchcraft and brought to life. And I hold
in my hand follow up from yesterday. Yesterday,
I talked about a lawsuit filed by Dominion
Voting Systems against Newsmax, Ohayon or
One Americanus, and Patrick Byrne, who apparently
is the CEO of Overstock.com. They're being
sued for defamation in a wide ranging multi,
multi, hundreds of millions of dollars, like
a one point two billion dollar lawsuit for
defamation in their pursuit of election. Propaganda,
the big lie that Donald Trump didn't, in fact
lose and Joe Biden didn't, in fact, win. Even
though they come with zero evidence, they
play their weird propaganda movies on own,
produced by my pillow ding dong. It is all
surreal and in this lawsuit, this two hundred
thirteen page lawsuit, it really also illuminates
another issue related to the right, and that
is their dedication to propaganda, their dedication
to the lies they're they're propping up of
figures who are not of any repute as experts.
And that is the case that I want to talk about
today, and that is from January of twenty
twenty one, and put a guy on the air promoting
him as a as an expert math mathematician,
a professional holding expertize in advanced
mathematics when in fact, spoiler alert, I'll
get to it. He is not a mathematician. He holds
no degrees. He is in fact a a convicted drug
dealer. And according to the lawsuit, a an
installer of swing sets who claimed made wild
claims that some algorithm flipped through
the election through complex mathematical
things that go way beyond my ability. I'm
going to read a little bit from this lawsuit
because it is remarkable. Starting on page
one or one, if you happen to have a copy of
it or you're reading along on January twenty
seven, twenty twenty one OEM broadcast a segment
hosted by Trump campaign affiliate Christina
Bob. She's an old employee in which she interviewed
a supposed quote unquote, expert mathematician
named Ed Solomon, who claimed he had uncovered
mathematical evidence proving that the November
20, 20 election results were, quote unquote,
impossible, and that therefore, quote, computer
software must have used an algorithm to change
the votes, end quote. Must have been the case,
Solomon claimed that the results, quote, can
only have been done by an algorithm, it can't
be done by humans, unquote, says the swing
set installer, after he supposedly analyzed
the results in Fulton County, Georgia, where
Dominion machines were used to tabulate votes.
He then claimed that the odds. All right.
Now, listen to this. This is one dangerous,
scary that we were on the brink of having
an election overturned. This is serious, but
it's also laughable. That an actual network,
apparently all it takes to create a network,
to spread propaganda and to gin up fear and
whip Republicans into a frenzy is to have
a few million dollars laying around and willing
to spend them on the creation of a TV network,
if you want to call it that one. America News,
which is based just a few miles down the road
from where I live in Southern California,
there in San Diego. This is what he said.
He then claimed that the odds of those results
occurring naturally were, quote, one over
ten to an exponent so large there's not enough
stars in the universe, comma, there aren't
enough atoms in the universe to explain the
number. You know, spoken like someone with
an advanced degree in mathematics. This is
what passes for expertize in the Republican
Party. It is disgusting, it is actually scary.
Moving on, Solomon's claims were ludicrous.
Ohayon do again. I'm reading from a lawsuit
here and at a minimum, recklessly disregarded
the truth on a new Solomons. Claims were false
because Dominion had expressly notified OCN
of independent evidence debunking them because
former President Donald Trump's own administration
had debunked them and because in itself had
effectively acknowledged it by secretly removing
several articles and broadcast from its own
website that made similar claims again. This
is not a reputable journalistic outlet that
is not this flies in the face of journalistic
standards, there are there are standard operating
procedures with journalists relative to correcting
the record. Listen, any endeavor that is run
by human beings is going to be fraught with
the possibility of. Incorrect information
getting something wrong, and they have rules
in place to make sure that they correct the
record, that they own the mistake, deleting
an article or deleting a video because it's
going to get you in legal hot water or because
it was wrong isn't the way to do it. You note
this article has been updated to reflect the
most accurate information, a previous a previous
edition of this article contained an incorrect
blah, blah, blah. There's a correction, a
mia culpa, if you will. That is not the case
with OCN because they are not a journalistic
outlet. They are a propaganda outlet serving
the the wild conspiracies of Donald Trump
serving at the mission and the behest of a
man who wants to tear down the fabric of democracy
in America. Continuing with the lawsuit, Ohayon
also new Solomons claims were bogus because
Solomon was the farthest thing imaginable
from an expert mathematician. He was, in fact,
a convicted felon with no college degree.
Nonetheless, only in broadcast and endorsed
as its own. Solomon's preposterous and baseless
allegations that the twenty twenty election
was rigged through computer algorithms Solomon
claimed were implemented in voting machines
in the very counties and jurisdictions that
used a Dominion machines. Now, other than
the fact that the sentence in this lawsuit
is in desperate need of a few commas. This
isn't looking good for OEI in. This isn't
looking good for Newsmax, and I'm going to
get to it. It's not looking good for even
Solomon here. Dominion notified. Oh, and this
is the crux of it, though. They they were
they were notified by OEI and all of all these
things and they still continued to do what
they did for months. They're still doing it.
In fact, Dominion notified Ohayon that Solomon
was no expert mathematician and that he was
actually a convicted drug dealer who never
graduated college and whose current job was
setting up swing sets in Long Island, New
York, at some point thereafter, and quietly
removed the videos and story from its originally
published location on its website. But the
video remains available on Owen's Rumbold
page and on another landing page on its main
website. Again, this is what passes for journalism
and this is what passes for truth. In conservative
circles